[Music]
would you say you have a type of guy
that you want you just usually somebody
with a pulse no III I'm all over the map
I seriously I dated a wrestler for a
little while last year was he well-known
was he uh I think maybe I don't know III
we dated and like I couldn't remember
the names of the wrestlers I'd be like
did you beat stillborn like just
guessing at C we were terrible or a
great name I don't know we were just
very different sexually like he was very
active in bed you know and like moving
around in my style I like like laying
there so just when you're I think using
like such good shape when you're naked
with someone you want to be the one
bringing the Thunder you know I want to
be able to whisper things like you're
welcome or it's like you owe me for this
like that kind of you owe me for this
yeah just whatever comes to your mind
yeah I think did you bring this you
brought a picture I'm told I have not
seen it but this is the guy that you
bring a picture yeah no that's provided
by your there he is oh that's a guy
who's ready to go he it was ready I'm
used to dating kind of like chubby ish
comics when they take their shirts off
you're like how are you not a woman like
that
[Applause]
it was bad yeah bad
how are you enjoyed the show inside Amy
Schumer I'm just hearing fantastic
things are you having a good time I am
I'm so excited for people to see it I
think it's really funny I made it just
for you and Andy like it's actually yeah
it's you're my target demo so please
watch everything we have a business plan
yeah cast a wider net we have a clip
here for something called slap chef yes
this is I just feel like we're all so
lazy with weight loss like we just want
to be able to I was just standing in a
hot tub in Vegas one weekend and I'm
trying to get booked at Brad's club and
I was thinking like why can't I be
exercising by just standing here sure
that's what that's every American's
dream right so this is like an
infomercial about a new weight-loss plan
for Americans let's take a look at this
clip Amy you look amazing how'd you do
it with slap shot with slap chef slap
chef first would have slap chefs
world-class chefs makes you one of their
signature dishes then before you can say
slap chef big knock it out of your
stupid mouth slap chef sandwiches watch
a flapjack fettuccine alfredo laughs
yeah
you've tried slap chef but that hurt
yeah I just do nothing
okay wait Tim are you from safety after
we induce you into a coma
I'm off to the gym hiking kickboxing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]